ich habe das Thema aufgebracht
Proteste in Deutschland ich hoffe Zeit
nicht dass er seinen Protest Winter
geben wird ich wäre aber auch nicht
überrascht wenn die Proteste im Winter
zunehmen wichtig ist dass man nicht nur
die Oberfläche des Geschehens ansieht
sondern begreift wie sich das nun seit
etlichen Jahren aufschichtet denken wir
zurück an die Unzufriedenheit oder
besser gesagt an die Sorgen vieler
Deutschen ob der deutschen Rolle in der
Euro Rettungspolitik Übernahme von
Bürgschaften Garantien für dieses und
jenes nach der
[Applaus]
eurozonenpolitik kommt dann die große
Migrationspolitik wir schaffen das und
es ist unmöglich eine Obergrenze von
etwa 200.000 Leuten pro Jahr die wir
aufnehmen einzuführen inzwischen haben
wir 200.000 Asylbewerber heuer und dazu
wohl 1,1 Millionen Ukraine wir schaffen
das doch alle und dann kommen Briefe von
Landräten und fragt sich der Bürger ob
wir das wirklich schaffen dann kommt
oben drauf auch noch die Ver Schwerpunkt
der Energie und die deutsche Haltung im
ukrainekrieg bzw korrekter im Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine an dieser
Stelle fragen sich viele Bürger weist
die Politik eigentlich was sie tut ist
es wirklich wohl überlegt Atomkraftwerke
abzuschalten wenn man anschließend ein
stabiles Netz haben will wo es ja eine
bestimmte Grundlastversorgung braucht
die eben durch die flüchtigen oder die
unsteten Energien Wind und Sonne nicht
erzeugt werden kurz und die Bürger
fragen sich weist die Politik was sie
tut deswegen wurde dann immer wieder
protestiert diese Protestbewegung haben
sich aufeinander aufgeschichtet es gibt
zum Teil personelle Kontinuitäten und
immer mehr Leute kamen dazu und es zeigt
sich dass die alte Strategie die von
Politik und Medien gefahren worden ist
ein weniger und weniger verfängt als wir
die
eurozonen Kritik hatten da war das
Argument wer nicht begreift dass der
Euro Europa zusammenhält und den Frie
gespeichert ist ein Europa Feind ein
europa-gegner und wir sind Europa Gegner
Nationalisten als die migrationskritik
kam da war die Aussage die gegen eine
bunte Gesellschaft können nur Rassisten
etwas haben also grenzt man sie aus als
dann die Proteste gegen die
corona-politik kommen da waren es
Extremisten die demokratische Politik
nicht akzeptieren wollen das heißt der
Staat ist allmählich hilflos in Bezug
auf diesen Bürgerprotest die alten
Rezepte funktionieren nicht mehr das
merken die Bürger wiederum und so sind
wir in einer aufschaukelnden Spirale und
wir alle warten darauf dass man Weg
finden diese Spirale ändern zu
durchbrechen das ist tatsächlich ein
guter Punkt also man sieht immer mehr
wenn jemand gegens narrativ spricht wenn
jemand Kritik äußert dass man immer mehr
diffamiert wird stigmatisiert wird
gebrandmarkt wird dass man irgendwie ja
in irgendeine Schublade gesteckt wird um
nicht auf die Argumente einzugehen weil
man vielleicht auch keine Gegenargumente
hat man wird persönlich angegriffen weil
man dann sich der Argumentation nicht
hingeben und das ist eine
brandgefährliche Entwicklung für die
Debattenkultur und für unseren Diskurs
den wir eigentlich brauchen und dann
gibt es nicht mehr sie haben vollkommen
recht sobald man irgendwie wagt was zu
kritisieren wird man sofort diffamiert
und es ist daran krank unsere komplette
Gesellschaft und bei Corona was ganz
besonderes deutlich selten ein Blatt vor
den Mund das nie würde ich sagen ich
wollte ihn ja auf Twitter
dementsprechend ist mir sehr sympathisch
über dementsprechend die Frage erleben
Sie das auch persönlich dieses
diffamiert werden oder absolut etwas
dadurch auch verlieren ja jeden Tag
jeden Tag also durch meine Grundhaltung
dass ich halt von Anfang an skeptisch
war zum Beispiel bei den
corona-maßnahmen oder beiden Euro
Rettungsmaßnahmen habe ich natürlich
sehr viel Gegenwind bekommen teilweise
auch Shitstorms und meistens war es aber
nicht fundierte Gegenargumente sondern
es war immer eigentlich nur eine Art ja
Stigmatisierung ne nach dem Motto ja
redet nicht mit dem weil und so weiter
also lassen dann hat man irgendwie
versucht jemanden irgendeine Schublade
zu stecken und daran krank unsere
komplette Debattenkultur seit Jahren wer
Auszeit muss auch einstecken können
dementsprechend ich bin aber sie Stör
ich bin absolut offen für für eine
konstruktive pluralistische
Gesellschaften für den Austausch und für
Kritik und für konstruktive Kritik aber
fundiert und nicht irgendwie unter der
Gürtellinie oder persönlich diffamieren
nur nach dem Motto wenn man den jetzt
irgendwie sagen das ist ein Spur blau
oder irgendwie ein Querdenker da muss
man erst gar nicht auf die Argumentation
eingehen das ist so einfach und das
sehen wir seit Jahren seit angefangen
mit der Euro-Krise whatever it takes
damals und als ich gesagt habe leute das
ist ein riesen Problem das geht nicht
wurde ich hart angegriffen genauso ist
auch während der corona-krise aber haben
wurden sie auch praktisch diffamiert
oder es ist glücklicherweise ja nur im
Netz und da wird ihn verloren also wenn
sie Wikipedia lesen oder so dann ist man
sofort irgendwie eher rechts einzuordnen
was ich wahrlich nicht bin und es ist
schon ein brandmarkt weil viele Google
halt erstmal am gucken aha Frau
Brockhaus und dann guckt mal was macht
ihr denn eigentlich so oder kommt mal
irgendwann auf Wikipedia und das ist
schon ja Stigmatisierung finde ich der
Menschen und es geht so nicht wir müssen
wieder in wir müssen Brücken bauen dann
müssen wir dann da reden das ist ja die
die Macht die die Menschen haben dass
wir kommunizieren können miteinander und
dass wir auch andere mein akzeptieren
wir hatten ja auch recht wir hatten ja
auch mit vielen Punkten recht weiter
Eurokrise mit der Inflation oder auch
bei Corona die ganze Wahrheit trifft
sich ja gerade ihren Weg Sachen die wir
vor allem wenn ich sagen durften da
werden wir gecancelt worden auf Youtube
dürfen wir jetzt sagen
wir wurden mit Fell nach noch nie auf
Youtube gecancelt und hier wurde alles
auf den Tisch gebracht muss ich sagen
also muss ich sagen ich lebe hier im
Reich der Meinungsfreiheit aber ich
stimme natürlich zu dass es da Probleme
gibt mit Kritikern die diffamiert werden
wie ist es denn bei dir Sebastian du
wirst wahrscheinlich nicht diffamiert du
bist auch natürlich also wenn man
alleine mal das Beispiel wenn ich jetzt
aber mal es gibt wieder irgendwo anders
also wenn alleine stehen vor
Messerattacke so etwas und dann teilst
du bei Facebook einen Text und schreibst
darüber das ist ja schrecklich was da
passiert ist so was passiert dann dann
kommen gleich Leute Mensch warum
interessiert dich das denn überhaupt und
so immer so verwirrende Tore von wegen
du bist ja rechts und so da kommt da
kommen keine Gegenargument wenn ich aus
Migrationspolitik in der Tat daraus auch
seine Ableitung treffen und dann kann es
ist schon ein Problem wenn Menschen aus
sehr brutalisierten Gesellschaften in
großer Zahl kommen
da kommt eine solche Keule Menschen
wenden sich ab in Freunden einen sagt
ach der ist jetzt hier irgendwie rechts
und so das ist keine Diskussionskultur
wir müssen den anderen wieder achten wir
müssen inhaltlich diskutieren innerlich
gegenhalten und nicht sagen das ist ein
gefährlicher Spieler was hat man in der
Realität zu befürchten die Frage gerne
an sie beide an sie drei was hat man in
der Realität zu befürchten also Twitter
Shitstorms kenne ich zu genüge ich habe
da auch den Namen Masken Nena weil ich
immer gegen die maskenpflicht war das
akzeptiere ich auch das das Stufe ich
aber unter Gegenwind 1 das finde ich
gehört zur meinungsfrei dazu ich
kritisiere andauernd man soll mich auch
kritisieren Hass ist zwar nicht gut aber
ich nehme das hin ist es denn in der
Realität so dass sie Probleme haben
obwohl sie sagen es geht weiter ja
tatsächlich also ich habe tatsächlich
Freunde verloren wirklich gut ich dachte
es wären gute Freundschaft Scheiße
selbst innerhalb der Familie gibt es
eine Spaltung dass ich nicht mehr das
beste eingeladen wurde oder so weil ich
eine starke Meinung vertrete und
natürlich habe ich auch also
wirtschaftlich Probleme gehabt dass
Kunden sich von mir abgewendet haben
oder sich böse Briefe bekommen oder
sogar sehr böse E-Mails teilweise mit
Drohungen und das ist dann schon wo ich
sage okay hier ist auch wieder eine
Grenze überschritten aber ich spüre das
oft oder sie auch angesprochen werde im
Zug nach Berlin oder so nach dem
Motorrad sie sind doch der der gegen den
Euro ist und sie sind doch jetzt
irgendwie in Euro hasse und Nationalist
umso Späße also völlig absurd ne
irgendwas aufgeschnappt irgendwie nicht
wirklich verarbeitet und einfach nur
raus posaunt und das ist es das Schlimme
eigentlich sobald man irgendwie versucht
mal mit Daten Fakten zu argumentieren
dann bekommt man gleich massiven
Gegenwind aber ohne Gegenargumente das
stört mich am allermeisten diese
Diffamierung sie kennen das auch Frau
Schüller selbstverständlich und das ist
genau das Problem man muss Fakten auch
auf den Tisch bringen können wenn sie
anderen nicht passen wir erleben das oft
genug in der unstatistik der Kolumne bei
der ich mit mitschreibe wo wir einmal im
Monat eine schlechte Statistik
auseinander nehmen wenn wir schreiben
dass die Impfung von 90 Prozent nicht
heißt dass 90 Prozent der Menschen
geschützt sind vor Corona kriegen wir
Gegenwind wir würden die Menschen vom
Impfen abhalten wenn wir schreiben die
Korrelation zwischen Impfungen und
Übersterblichkeit ist es falsch es
statistisch falls können wir Gegenwind
von der anderen Seite als ich im August
2020 von einem Kollegen von ihnen BILD
am SONNTAG gefragt wurde ja wo geht es
denn hin mit den Fallzahlen bis Herbst
habe ich gesagt ja okay irgendwo 5000
bis 20.000 kam die Schlagzeile diese
statistikerin sagt wir hätten bis zu
20.000 Fälle im Herbst was ich an
E-Mails bekommen habe Panikmache und so
weiter also am Ende einfach nur noch
ungesehen gelöscht dann hatten wir
20.000 Fälle im Herbst auf einmal hieß
es das ist die statistikerin die 20.000
Fälle vorher gesehen hat ja aber man
muss solche Fakten einfach auf den Tisch
bringen dass das Mathematik das sind
Daten man kann solche Dinge berechnen
ohne dass man wahlweise als Verharmloser
oder als Panikmacher beschimpft wird